my next recipe is an old classic roast
chicken but with a simple twist
it takes on a new life and it's
guaranteed to impress
one of the things i love about cooking
and that keeps me excited after 25 years
behind the stove
is that there's always something new to
learn every day new ingredients
new techniques and new cuisines
start off with the stuffing it's amazing
how
exciting a stuffed roast chicken can be
because it keeps the chicken incredibly
moist and gives a delicious texture
inside the bird i'm going to start off
with cured
cereso this is a traditional spanish
sausage and it's
garlicky spicy incredibly meaty
that gives a little bit of sort of
richness to the stuffing get that
chorizo
in start cooking that down
and getting all those oils out a little
touch
of olive oil in there to get it going
right onions
chopped add the onions to the cerezo
and in a matter of seconds they'll
change color as they soak up all the
flavor
that lovely spiciness has been stolen
from that sausage now the onions smell
incredible
garlic garlic
fresh thyme just hold it down and get
your fingers on there and it's a really
nice way of taking off all those nice
fragrant little time flowers
you can hear crackling in the background
these are cannellini beans they're waxy
very soft and so delicious but very
dense
but for stuffing they're so robust
nothing breaks down
drain them off
in they're going to take on all that
juice as well from the freezer
i'm going to season them now because
they're very dense so it needs some help
that looks like it's a dish on its own
good enough to eat now
i want to sweeten things up a little bit
tomatoes
half dried in that sweetens up
the stuffing beautiful
the stuffing's ready look at the color
everything looks spanish it looks
delicious
now stuffing the chicken i like taking
off these
little knuckles as the chicken cooks
the skin stretches over the bone you can
get a really nice drum
and take off those little wingtips as
well salt pepper
so important now
you're stuffing i'm gonna go right
inside the chicken
push it down this really helps to cook
the bird evenly because you're
pushing out all the empty spaces in the
carcass
and take a nice large lemon
push the lemon in pick up the parsley's
nose
pull the skin over olive oil on top
salt and pepper
a teaspoon of paprika sprinkle it on
and then get your hands and sort of
rub that in and see what the paprika is
doing to the chicken
putting this like sweet spicy marinade
it's not even roasted yet but it looks
delicious
[Music]
400 ml of white wine same quantity of
water that helps
the chicken to steam chicken in
be generous with the time sprigs
[Music]
make sure the fall is folded tightly
around the roasting tray so the chicken
steams in the oven
keeping it moist and juicy into the oven
cook for one hour at 180 degrees with a
foil on
nice take it out and remove the full lid
then give it another 30 minutes to crisp
up that skin
[Music]
look at that it's so important to make
sure you take that tinfoil off with half
an hour to go
beautiful pierce that open squeeze it
in that delicious gravy mix that into
the tray
and sieve that
that's really nice fragrant lemony
spiced
roasting juices to finish
before we cut up the chicken take out
amazing stuffing
[Music]
incredible i'd have that with chicken
over potatoes any day
and then just get your chicken roasting
juices
now to cut the chicken up
hold the drum and slice straight through
and there's a wonderful drum and the
thigh
through the wishbone
off slice with the point at an angle so
you can see the texture
of that amazing roast chicken just take
my cooking juices
just want to give a nice sort of lemony
flavor
over my chicken and there you go
a delicious very charming stuffed
roast chicken
my next recipe is easy and a pleasure to
make if you're organized with everything
ready in advance
[Music]
miso poached salmon with asian
vegetables
organization is key in the kitchen take
a couple of minutes before you start
and set yourself up make sure you know
where everything is
stock spatula pan etc it becomes less
stressful but more importantly the end
results
are incredible
[Music]
first off get your pan on whisk
and stock start off with this amazing
fermented
soy bean puree into the pan three nice
tablespoons
gas on now get your fish stock and whisk
into the puree be generous with the
stock
you want this nice light broth
basically you can buy miso paste from
big supermarkets and it works
brilliantly with salmon
poaching the salmon in the miso stuff
gives it a really nice sort of
sweet earthy creamy flavor it's
incredible
bring it to the bowl i'm gonna infuse
the broth
and make it a little bit more fragrant
kaffir lime leaf is very lemony
inside the miso broth then chopped chili
chilli's in and finely sliced ginger
that's simmering beautifully now we're
going to poach the salmon
poaching means cooking it in liquid but
it's cooked gently
and the secret here is to keep that
salmon skin on if we took the skin off
now
the salmon can actually break up whilst
it's poaching
skin side down i'm just going to slide
that in
under nice the minute that stock
starts boiling turn it down let it
simmer
take a little ladle and just every
couple of minutes
pour over that make sure the top of the
salmon is cooked evenly
and keeps it nice and moist and poaching
is one of the most delicate ways of
cooking so you have to handle it
with care whilst the salmon's poaching
in the miso broth
start preparing your vegetables i'm
using tender stem broccoli
and bak choy i always like to cook
the leaf and the stem separately the
leaf is like sort of spinach
and the stem is so much thicker it's
almost as thick as a stick of celery
so i like to get the stems sliced
just so i've got that nice sort of
christmas place the leaves together
nicely roll them up nice and tight
and then slice them down
now my salad already the flavor
in that broth has been elevated
it tastes really fishy you've got the
heat the chili
spiciness the ginger and the caffeine
lime leaf
take your fish slice and place it very
gently underneath the salmon and push it
down
fish slices are flexible for that reason
bend it
lift it up just touch looking for a
springy
firm texture and just
sit there on top a little touch of the
broth over it
it stops it from drying out leave that
to cool down for two minutes
bring the stock back up to the boil
broccoli and
bak choy stems in a little taste
it's getting better and better and
better cook
the broccoli and the bok choy stems for
one minute and then add
the tops in turn the salmon into your
hand
and just peel all that skin off the skin
also
helps to keep the salad nice and moist
then gently flake the salmon
that's the secret behind poaching
everything just stays
so moist wonderful long shards of
pink now just before we serve
we're going to add our mushrooms these
are enoki mushrooms you can buy these in
oaky mushrooms in big supermarkets and
good grocers
slice them off i'm going to put half in
and the other half
i'm gonna serve with the salmon toasted
sesame seed oil
put a little drip in there just rub
and you're just lining almost like a
little coat of varnish
start off with your mushrooms and then
my salmon
four nice layers and then finally
the mushrooms top with the vegetables
and then finally a nice ladle
that beautiful really sumptuous
rich stock
lovely and that is an amazing
misu poached salmon soup simplify your
cooking by getting organized and amazing
food will be coming out your kitchen
every day whether it's breads cakes
tarts pies or pastries
bacon is one of the most seductive
skills in the kitchen
it fills the house with fantastic aromas
and puts irresistible food
on the table
now i'm gonna put you on the road to
bacon nirvana starting with an easy
bread
packed with big gutsy flavors olive
tomato and rosemary for catcher
absolutely love bacon bread there's
something really satisfying about doing
it
and this focaccia recipe is very
hands-on but
the end result is something really
really tasty
first off start with the dough tip 500
grams of strong bread flour into a
mixing bowl
and add 20 grams of semolina
that gives the focaccia its sort of
rustic charm
now there's one thing for catching needs
it's really good seasoning
you can't season bread after it's baked
so it's got to go in right at the very
beginning
sprinkling 15 grams of dried yeast take
some warm water
and then 50 ml of olive oil top of that
water
that gives it this really nice silky
rich texture
make a little well mix up that yeast
water
and oil in start off with your fingers
keep your fingers nice and open it's
like a little sort of whisk
going in there i'm looking for a really
nice sort of relaxed
dough
now that's just starting to come
together touch more water
with the oil in there give it a little
swirl and then again
the secret is to sort of knead it gently
don't overwork it it's a sort of
easy bread to make a nice one to start
off with when you're making bread for
the first time
basically kneading means just knit it
together just hanging
lightly flour your board and let's just
knead that focaccia
into a nice smooth dough make sure you
don't over add
too much flour otherwise it sort of
dries out the dough
something quite magical about making
bread you can switch off
and lose yourself my first job for a
three mission star establishment
was a baker i was 22 years of age i used
to start at midnight
i was under such a tight schedule one
o'clock
white bread then two o'clock brown bread
three o'clock sourdough
four o'clock cheese bread five o'clock
proof bake
six o'clock crack them open and taste
it was amazing beautiful
yeah looks stunning it hasn't even risen
yet
leave your dough to rise in a warm place
until it's doubled in size
we call this proving
[Music]
that beautiful a lot of chefs sort of
need it for the second time but i'm
looking for a really nice light
aerated for catcher take a tray
a touch of olive oil in there season it
at the bottom
really important that's the exciting
thing about focaccia you've got that
really nice
sort of salty top and salty bottom
and just with a touch of olive oil on
your hands
gently push that in and almost massage
it into the corners
it's possible to put sort of olives and
tomatoes and garlic
through the dough but it never really
allows the dough to sort of
aerate properly when you put so much
ingredients in
i'm going to stick mine on top use your
finger and sort of just push them in
salt on top some pepper on top as well
i want some nice fresh amazing rosemary
just hold the stalk
and just pull off and then just sprinkle
down
generous in the rosemary really
important to have that nice
fragrance on top of the fuckacha finish
it off before it goes in
with a little drizzle of olive oil so it
almost sinks in those little pockets of
flavor olive tomato rosemary
and olive oil into the oven
[Music]
bake your focaccia at 200 degrees for 30
to 35 minutes
smells delicious
[Music]
beautiful
[Music]
you can hear how crispy that is you
can't beat
a nice warm fresh slice of home-cooked
focaccia
it's rustic charming and it's the
perfect way
to start baking making homemade for
catcher
it's so addictive
getting to grips with bacon is just a
matter of confidence
slow cooking is one of the best weapons
in the chef's arsenal not only is it
easy
it's also an incredible way to transform
meat into mouthwateringly melting dishes
mastering the art of slow cooking is
something every cook should learn
first up my phenomenal slow cooked beef
short ribs
slow cooking is a brilliant way of
getting lots of extra depth and
intensity into your dishes
the secret is to lock in all those
flavors at the start and let the
ingredients do their thing
as it cooks
these are beef short ribs and there's
basically
five to six bones across there and as
the short rib cooks it sticks that bone
the bone implants flavor
and the meat just sort of melts cooks
slowly gives it that nice level
intensity
slice alongside the bone straight down
you can see that marbling
that sort of disappears and
disintegrates i'm cooking them in a
roasting tray
get it on the heat until nice and hot
season
these short ribs beautifully
olive oil in bone on the top we'll start
coloring that
in
[Music]
really important to give the beef short
rib a really nice sear
if you didn't brown the meat off it goes
in the oven
and it looks like boiled meat so you
really want that nice
dark rich coloring just cut the garlic
in half slide that down the side that's
going to give that beef
an amazing flavor
[Music]
to give body to the sauce stir in a
heaped teaspoon of tomato puree
i'm just hitting the bottom of the pan
with that tomato puree
and we call it cooking out that smell of
puree
otherwise it just goes in there raw and
it gives this sort of
tartness to the braised short ribs red
wine in
don't use an expensive bottle of red
wine there's no need
bring the wine up to the boil and reduce
it this burns off the alcohol and
concentrates the flavor
it makes a big difference when you
reduce the red wine down by half because
it gives that nice
dark rich intensity
look at my garlic that is just gonna
sweeten everything up incredible
stock in beef stock perfect
chicken stock fine
just to about an inch underneath the
beef short ribs
bring it up to the ball to lock in all
that flavor
as the beef ribs slow cook cover them so
they braise from the bottom
and steam from the top into the oven two
and a half hours
170 to 180 degrees
in she goes the great thing about slow
cooking is
you do most of the work in advance and
then put your feet up
five or ten minutes before the beef
short ribs come out of the oven
start your garnish this is light cured
pancetta
we want nice thick lardons nice big
thick sticks of crispy bacon
these are delicious chestnut mushrooms
i'm not going to slice them
i'm just going to cut them in half but
look at the color on those lardons now
all the whites raw fat have disappeared
the lardons have shrunk right down and
all we've got there now is the proper
bacon
mushrooms in beautiful so the mushrooms
get
seasoned from the bacon i'm pan frying
these separately to the beef so they
remain crisp
and have a different texture
[Music]
leave that to cool down now this is like
christmas day for me when you unwrap
that fall once you see what's underneath
[Music]
it
wow they smell
incredible lift and place
on your tray beautiful
to make a fantastic rich deep sauce
press the soft roasted garlic through a
sieve
into the cooking juices when all that
nice
pureed garlic coming through there
because that is going to make the most
amazing
flavor scrape all of that
off the sieve nice
and then just start sieving
all that lovely braising liquor
in that smells delicious
take your sauce and just glaze
do them individually they deserve that
respect
spoon on your bacon and your mushrooms
beautiful be generous with these
mushrooms i'm telling you
they taste amazing flat leaf parsley
all that freshness over those amazing
ribs
incredible never ever be embarrassed
about going to your butcher
and asking for cheap cuts because the
results
are incredible amazing beef braised
short ribs
with bacon and mushrooms
you